We Begin this half hour with the
occasion that brought Britain's Prince
William and Princess Kate to Boston the
awarding of the earth shot prizes dud
the Oscars of the earth they recognize
and reward Innovative projects
addressing climate change and other
serious environmental problems this
morning Remy and ascencio shows us one
of the winners and the work that could
solve a truly ocean-sized problem
I can announce that the 2022 Earth shot
for build a waste free world goes to
nopla
and it was completely surreal
Pierre Posley is co-founder of
london-based nutpla a little wordplay of
not plastic his startup of determined
designers chemists and Engineers won
Prince William's Earth shot award for
environmental Innovation and more than
one million dollars their mission to
replace single-use plastic with
single-use seaweed for the planet and
its people a revolution we have to look
at it as a war effort because the the
scale of like the challenge is something
that threatens the whole world all at
once it's in the air it's in water it's
in our blood we produce 400 million tons
of plastic waste every year says the
United Nations half of that's used just
once then thrown away much of it to live
hundreds of years after we are gone but
it's very slowly fragmenting and
releasing all of these other chemicals
that are present in the plastic and the
the half-life of plastic being hundreds
of years we're not going to see the peak
of that for a very long time right we're
basically poisoning ourselves in our
future Generations a poison like no
other the antidote is in nature seaweed
is one of the planet's most renewable
resources it grows fast some up to three
feet in a day and it's resilient 12 000
species are found in every ocean in the
world not pla has experimented with
about 30 of them concocting secret
seaweed sauces and turning them into
transparent films it's like plastic wrap
but seaweed wrap how strong it will
break but it's definitely resistant
enough for a lot of applications where
there's going to be relatively quick
consumption like the Ojo little Jiggly
pods for liquid on the go they've been
trialled with success at marathons and
concerts where piles of plastic bottles
are the unfortunate Norm today's flavor
is lemon mint water Cheers Cheers here
we go put it in your cheek it's going to
explode yeah all right and then you can
eat the whole thing a little nervous
there's that pop that is a pop not plot
is making more form factors for
condiments too like ketchup mayonnaise
and olive oil if its packaging ends up
in landfill nature makes quick work of
it in four to six weeks for now Posley
says not Paws products aren't price
competitive with plastic but commercial
Partnerships are key the companies
teamed up with a UK food delivery app
for seaweed line boxes replacing plastic
lining tie-ups with bigger Brands he
hopes are a matter of time bringing the
best solutions to the brands like
McDonald's and and KFCs and Burger King
not plus simple guiding principle to
repair our damaged Planet nature knows
best for CBS Saturday morning raymie and
asensio London
really interesting and once you get the
price down that's the big thing right
yeah I like that tagline though nature
knows best nature absolutely very
Innovative and especially after marathon
races you always see so many things
littered around it's nice to know there
is a possible solution right maybe let's
see